Jesus I was gonna say though like
I always have like a
I love Bay Area Music yeah but I always
feel like the music that gets embraced
out of the bay it almost only gets
embraced if it sounds a certain way
Taylor Regional like we have a guy named
John Coston who we probably both know
he's a slimy bastard shout out to John I
love him yeah but like I'm the slimiest
of the slimiest but like you know when
I'm talking to him about like yourself
or guys like little Russell I feel like
the excitement's not there as opposed to
if I'm talking to him about like they
want us to put guns in the video I don't
know I just it's just frustrating
because I'm like yo sometimes I feel
like how is it in my opinion you and the
Russell in my opinion are like the next
like Jay-Z and like Nas like little
Russell is going to change the music
industry based off of his business model
the music is good like you're just like
I think the new Hove you know what I'm
saying and I feel like
up until like everybody outside of the
bay was [ __ ] with you it didn't feel
like the people inside of the bay were
[ __ ] with you you know
Coca-Cola was the first Cola to be a
brand
they didn't take
heat of Pepsi too much when it first
came around right all right so Pepsi had
to become the drink of the generation so
it related to a new demographic and
what's going on is me and larussa are
relating to a different demographic than
what typically you see in the bay right
so because of that you're going to get
class you're going to get a little push
back because people have been doing it
one way for so long they look at it like
who the [ __ ] are y'all right to come
change what the [ __ ] is going on and
that's cool we're not trying to change
what's going on he's trying to offer
some balance I just want to relate to a
broader audience and me and Russell talk
about this a lot same thing with Rex
life Raj who's incredible yeah same
thing with a little Kayla you know like
everybody's looking to expand we tired
of being the city that just get looked
at as like the little cousin of LA right
you know what I mean it's like we bigger
than that we could be bigger as well but
sometimes our music doesn't translate
because well you guys don't also like
make like traditional at least what we
look at as Bay Area records yeah you
know what I'm saying and to me that's
like I think that that is why I love the
bay because I love Bay Area Music but I
also feel like it is also what makes the
ceiling a little bit harder to break
through because it is a bit Regional but
and you know like being down here like I
remember last year was a bunch of people
that felt like I was actually from L.A
right you know people that actually see
me in the bay working and playing
working for years like oh yeah L.A [ __ ]
but it's like nah I'm just trying to
expand it I'm trying to do something
different than just we all get hot go to
Petaluma go to Fresno go to Sacramento
go to Seattle
what comes after that right why can't we
be on the level of a Kendrick even if
bootleg Kev caused the album number five
and Kendrick number two why can't we be
on the level of a Freddie Gibbs even
though bootleg Kev calls it number five
why can't we be on a level we get it we
get it you know so we got to make bigger
records and we got to stick together
because people like bootleg Kev has it
um
called the project number one but he has
went to the Russell's backyard so we we
appreciate that I was definitely in
Vallejo I stayed in the hotel we live
Crest we loved it shout out to the
Russell too because he's doing amazing
[ __ ] by the way the uh Hampton Inn right
across the street from that 7-Eleven in
Vallejo and the across the street
my hotel that for two nights was in
Vallejo it was
[ __ ] lit no we was at uh what's the
name of that liquor store King's Liquor
yeah it's great I had the Mac Dre soda
yeah you know Vallejo is a very cultural
place no it's great yeah we had good
food there great Asian food that's an
old Vallejo